hello and welcome back to another
episode of top 5 Skyrim mods of the week
and something of a return to normality
after three weeks of building pcs and
testing pcs and installing en B's and
I'm not cam promised I was going to be
but I'm not I'm sorry Lucy your scepter
I am Seb and this is Lucy James welcome
back again Lucy it's great to be here
Joe good the second hand chair
yeah the copilot's chair that's a good
chair to be it's like it's like you know
taking part but none of the real
responsibilities exactly well no you
have in fact all the responsibility this
week well exactly why do you have all
the responsibility this week oh because
this week is kind of themed around me
all mods are called Lucy and someone no
Lucy you picked a theme or themes so I
really wanted to go something that's
very dear to me that I like a lot is
Kingdom Hearts and so I thought why not
go for a greater Disney theme including
Kingdom including Kingdom Hearts and
sort of swerving around all those
copyright things yeah so much of how
well we swerved around as many of them
as we could not all of them but most of
them so how about we kick off with mod
number 1
and welcome to Skyrim sky while we're
looking at the sky
so our first mod is the Kingdom Hearts
Moon and Sun by Arry we have or early
kind of showing this mod off before but
we already had the moon last time so now
we've got the Sun anyway that is not the
only part of mod number one so we are
going to be forging some bespoke fancy
armors that are basically gonna turn us
into some characters from Kingdom Hearts
so this is the Cloud Strife / Roxas mods
there he is
oh look at him and there's Brooks's
Roxas looking all hooded and faceless so
there's organization 13 version of Roxas
and then we also have some of the
characters in birth by Sleep so you've
got Terra aqua and Ventus
oh he's tiny oh he's down here well sure
that's not deliberate so the creator of
this mod is roar oh no nevermind Lord
you are now
clouds drive Cloud Strife this armor
completely redoes him from top to bottom
which is why I've not got anything
poking through like bits of Kevin's head
or his vastly more manly chest and arms
than then say clouds are you gonna
heroine my friend oh wow yes yes he can
hurt plenty of people with his fists
though sharp edges across his knuckles
is what does all the damage and Roxas
what's he got on his head
bad colouring ah pretty good good little
ears it's not very high-rez but I think
that's probably fine it's meant to look
quite old-school right well I guess if
it's ripped from a ps2 game then that
makes sense
oh dear please straight to the groin
maybe they're just really jealous of
your super sweet spiky hair Oh still
going what did I just punch him in the
nuts yes you did I'm convinced I did
okay oh oh look it it's a face I was a
lot more spray than you'd think well
when you go for the jaw when you've got
like a big metal bangle on like that it
does tend to sort of leave some mild
stain itches she throwing up blood this
game is getting grimmer and grimmer by
the day that's what you get whoo miRs
he's so so nimble Oh God come here it's
cuz he's so we it's like trying to swat
flies in a bedroom yeah I got him but
obviously the shrink ray is not clouds
typical weapon either in the game he's
from or from Kingdom Hearts so maybe
we're shootin Ward number two
so Lucy we're Markov what is mod number
two's so mod number two is the Kingdom
Hearts
keyblades collection by Abe Froman
sausage king which is my face the
sausage king of California Chicago oh
he's from Chicago I should know I am Abe
Froman bond aflame circled life decisive
pumpkin ours for the night before
Christmas land ah look at them so this
one this one right is on Steam Workshop
which makes me think that it's been done
you know
legitimately so I don't understand why
the characters themselves aren't
available on Steam Workshop you have to
sort of go through some slightly more
you know nefarious yes nefarious is
right Keyblade just your regular
bog-standard Keyblade let's take a look
see what guys it's a bit of noxious
Liebig isn't it the thing in Kingdom
Hearts is the key blades are massive and
so of that beat I'm seeing small feet
there oh that's not a real I suppose
this guy's from Final Fantasy I see that
look took a like more of a modern-day
key like a patio door key yeah yeah it
would some work over keen with some raps
Hidden Dragon is the one you get from
doing the Mulan world uh-huh oh I get it
lucky to the dragon he's breathing
proper children and you cow alright
heals my weapon look at it
so is this clouds one no no so this is
one of Sorek and crafts ah and yeah just
take like forever oh yeah oh dear
surprisingly sharp at the tip given that
it's a mostly a flat point Oh cloud not
impervious where O's head not impervious
from separation of neck oh dear
so say if Don the head not knocking
someone's larynx out of their body is is
not what you'd expect to find in say
Kingdom Hearts this
this is like a kick in the childhood for
me oh really
well I say childhood like led it's funny
actually because I'm gonna find another
guard and kick them in the childhood -
yes
hidden dragon also very effective okay
let's see what else have we got here
little Bop on the heavy all right so I'm
gonna swap over to the monochrome in the
right monochrome
so big oh yeah really really bad my
horse now never shields hey adament
shield yoga shield save the king oh and
then the dream sword there we are
hey guys now it's a party welcome home
so I love that you see like a little
chunk of their flesh just go flying off
yeah through the shoulder they're very
weak they're gone in the water with you
in in swim swim like you mean it
shoo done yes yes let's see how well
this goes for you now that all your
friends lay dead oh sure key through the
heart and you're to blame okay Lucy it's
time for mod number three and we're in
radiant raiment for the first part of
two bits the mod number three what is it
so we are here to find a new follower
okay princess honor honor Anna her
name's Anna from frozen it's honor honor
it's all yeah looks like we found her
look hey look what she sucks at oh she
looks really working and was she so um
bronzed a little bit very bronzed for it
for someone who spent like ten years
inside
well no she was the one that was always
like I want to go adventuring so maybe
she just sat at the window long enough
that she you know bronzed up her face
like you know a truckers time this much
and actually it's uh it's coal dear oh
dear I don't know why do i naked this
dress by the way is a combination of two
other mods her usual attire is just a
bit bland boring so it's what I put her
in something nice and green pretty which
is recommended on her mod page so you'll
know where to go if you want to install
those hey it's Elsa's castle it looks
exactly like the one in the film yeah
except for the whole thing but the
thoughts nice and it's got all the
little icicles and it's all frosty and
light
isn't that pretty she's got some guards
she does have the chandelier but it's
not not quite as glamorous see last one
that's alright
got some little blue flames going on
here homely warm certainly got some big
ice statues are they are they living
yeah they are oh don't push it
oh god very fragile oh oh oh oh and now
she's attacking thank god they're
useless oh dear no wait we need to be
friends friends I say whoops now apart
from all the attacking she's doing else
is very okay to be fair this is much
more like the film with the with the
attacking oh oh okay oh wait no the
sisters are attacking each other
no it wasn't meant to be it is on
arrived so what uh yeah I'm sorry
totally so let's just talk this over
that's better let's try that again back
again are you here you are not invited
no you don't follow me
done that's really cool look how easy
that was okay well she's got some
possessions mm-hmm take us else's staff
and her plain cloak um and a book
winters spring
bonus speech Boni had had this before I
could have talked her into joining me
anyway the winter comes I walk alone I
want no bird to sing hold on
these are the lyrics to let it go what
are we supposed to sing this or is it is
it meant to me I love the snow the
crumbling snow it hangs on everything
ladies and gentlemen adele dazeem ah she
does not want to move it's my throne now
it's totally my throne let it go let go
I'm one with the wind and skin medica no
I have control over the air right also
save me women defend defend your man
defend your cloud Oh
Ana's down God she's weak death
everywhere what what Cathy you don't get
frozen that's the name of the movie it
is ha ha ha that's adorable
come on Elsa you're my favorite sister
sure she gone she's up Oh welcome back
well at time and the sun's made your
bones weak
alright time for mod number four we are
just outside the dawn star sanctuary and
there's a fun little ship that's gonna
take us to mod number four which is
called into the deep Atlantis Atlantis
this is by DJ 1994 I I used to see him
spin back in the day we need to get on
the ship and head to Saint belling's
Island what a journey that was perilous
there's so much drama going on in fact
so perilous I think we may have lost two
of our followers overboard read clue
read when you get to the harvoni and
district of Atlantis the once great city
of Atlantis has now become swallowed as
now become swallowed by the sea oh this
is so budget I'm taking it
we're not reading the whole thing Lucy
have you seen Atlantis the Disney movie
the very same I played the Game Boy
Advance
close enough cuz I've not seen the film
so you need it you reckon down here moon
door moon door through the main door
this is the water door of course Oh
oh dear we go back no we can't no it's
nothing but onwards now you know one way
journey it's full commitment this is
like a huge dungeon I think that
someone's made uh yeah who's this guy
those are traps and stuff your Merman oh
I don't sailor
let's be friends oh yeah so Barney this
dungeon is meant to be really quite
tough oh this is cool little roughage so
we're at Disney World
exactly very very thematic irrelevant ah
the green people of course it's the
Green Giant oh there are enemies Oh God
Oh God oh I'm gonna kill them all kill
them all huh death duel begin
platforming first platform complete boop
boop hmm miss Atlantis does feel quite
Atlantic I mean I haven't seen the film
but whether this many people in the in
the game at least I know who was that
free stuff
activate it I didn't do a damn thing let
me do something down there yeah yeah
well I'm going for it
into the water Geronimo oh jeez oh jeez
Oh
hopefully it's not death moon door the
second moon door
you have to dive down well good lord I
think we got god mode on we have super
drowned by now otherwise yes all the
comments on this mod basically yeah it's
hard
Oh what fire demons why were the
underworld
it's alright let's let's see if we can
find another layer of Hell 200 some
dream aura some headless tree Maura just
a random-ass bandit yeah so so
presumably he made it past the like the
hell demons in fact they all did and
then they were like I guess we should
just settle here oh yeah oh oh
climbing climbing alright if you don't
like platforming this is not the mod for
you well that's the way we need to go so
I see in were jumping on here how cool
how cool - cool finally home sweet home
oh wow okay silly death Hall is kind of
deathy kind of badass how did he die I
don't know right there that one how we
were it goes down that one goes down
and then it goes oh my god Oh oh my god
come on Boulder that's not fair that's
crashing play don't know not risking it
made it I am the champion of all things
the greeters I passed the room of death
yay
kill that guy a death Lord just after
you've done the death hole that seems
unfair Bob Murphy wait what what
both Murphy well I think this is
probably about as far as we're gonna get
without doing any more obscene platform
but this is a cool little dungeon if you
like a unique kind of challenge in
Skyrim whether you want the Disney
aspect of it or not although given all
the death this doesn't seem to feel very
Disney fitting no it's an it's like a
twisted Disney yeah all right well let's
uh let's move on to our final mod of the
day
I'm for the final mod of today's show
Lucy this one doesn't seem as Disney
theme what is it so this is kind of went
on a tangent well I found this one but
look it looks super cool yeah it is
monster mounts by gg7 7g g77 we we've
featured several of G g77 mods before
including some of his mount ones but
we've never done monster mounts and if
you have a little look around there are
a lot of monster well no she's my sister
but there are a lot of other monsters
just sort of hanging around the Whiterun
stables including a dragon there's a
spider some chorus so um let's see how
they are to ride yay
they will have their own names there he
is
majestic on the back ride Hey killings
easy from here oh you got quite quick as
well yeah that's pretty speedy oh this
guy I still missed turn it around turn
it around
why turning circle oh I think this is
happening yeah huh
ride Sebastian um go on what yeah yes
yes yes yes yes
yeah Sebastian you are King Sebastian
from The Little Mermaid there we go
oh it's come full circle again off he
goes on his wild adventures cloud and
Sebastian off together never to be
separated to the tiger hey it's like the
jungle book kind of shoot a con oh you
nailed it oh he's great look at the
speed he's going that I have to know
King Kong Kong good cool I'll get it
this
I like that they've all just been
dropped here and it's like yeah just hop
on who are
haha lovely runs with this head in the
air like having a great time ah running
sprinting is great dragon track Drago
Drago Drago Zuzu ha ha I put you through
college and this is how you repay me
Elsa come here you know what you got to
do it has been a pleasure and a
privilege Oh God
rolling chickens who would have thought
they'd be incredibly difficult to
maneuver oh okay here we go and it's
time to leave this place whoo come on
hold it together
you can do it hold it together cloud no
in eternity floating there it's how we
would have wanted to go not unlike a
cloud oh yeah you forever reign in this
Cup
you get to stay Lucy's I want a little
fun Disney themed adventure that was
full of nostalgia yeah well nostalgia
and death there was so much blood
yeah I've seen a lot of Disney stuff in
my time and there was never quite that
much ever maybe only saw like the edited
version I think I did you see the the
real stuff anyway I did promises there
was gonna be a return to a vague hint of
normality so I have put in some
questions and comments and we've got
lots over the last few episodes
considering we haven't been addressing
any so I picked a few we've also got the
vote back Lucy would you like to do the
first comment first comment is fine Olaf
Larson who says I love oh love I wasn't
a deliberate thing that was a subliminal
choice but Olaf thank you I tried to get
mods to work but you have to be a
full-time nerd to understand what the
heck to download and to get it all to
work I got a life besides gaming so f
that thanks Olaf what a good comment the
reason I put that in is because we've
now have done a how to mod Skyrim
sowed and and how to install an ENB
episode so theoretically you don't have
to be a full-time nerd anymore you just
need about 20 minutes for each episode
and you'll be a professional nerd and
you'll be able to do all of that easy
easy
next question uh from harsh V - V makes
me wonder how do we have such fantastic
graphics coming out of mods and not from
the multi-million dollar development how
indeed well two weeks ago I think we was
the one where we installed all of the
best graphics mods that we possibly
possibly could and got Skyrim looking
gorgeous bear in mind that it would only
have looked that good on a PC that can
run it at that spec so that's probably
the reason why I imagine they're those
million dollar million dollar companies
can probably make stuff look pretty good
- yeah yeah so it's mostly just so that
we can have it working on everyone's PC
or console or whatever whatever next one
I'll do this one I want to jump in
Espada
Quatro says how much would their new rig
cost to make myself so mark got all the
bits and pieces for them um
PC build and there was a lot of stuff
yeah Lucy I believe I told you how much
mark estimated it did so hmm roughly
rough guess is around fifteen hundred
pounds that's quite a lot which is quite
a lot yeah um that is also I think
including the original graphics card
that we were going to put in which was
the the super super super duper one yeah
it was the Radian r9 no it was the
Radian r9 290 yes yes that one I'm gonna
say that one plus all the extra little
bits and like cooling and all the fans
and the motherboard but everything it
was about 1,500 pounds but it does run
very well and yeah it's running Skyrim
for us today
next one please from Earth Gaming 190
can I use Steam Workshop mods and Nexus
mods at the same time I recall having
answered this several times but it gets
are so
often that I felt it was probably worth
revisiting yes you can you can use Steam
Workshop mods and Nexus mods all at the
same time because they effectively do
the same thing it's simply how the game
well it's simply how you download them
into your folder so by subscribing on
Steam you bring the same kind of files
into your game folder so they they work
the same and you can manage them in
either the Skyrim launcher or a Nexus
mod manager or kind of however you want
to do and if you have a non-steam
version of the game you can also tie
that game to steam so that you can still
use Steam Workshop so it all works is
genius it all comes together in the end
mmm mmm ohh ex review who also does
Skyrim mod videos who has gone to the
trouble of writing first what's he first
comment
what was he no I think so
maybe Thank You MMO X review keep
watching you watch my stuff and the last
one Lucy if you would oh um that's
pretty good name it's a great name shock
but holy oh my you pick this yo with
this one smoothly on i7 3770 ok gtx 690
and 16 gigabytes of ram yes it would
that is frankly a beast of a machine it
would absolutely tear those mods to
pieces whatever those but holy oh yeah
visa yeah that would run those mods
right up the butthole EO as you might
put it anyway so that's all the comments
and feedback it's been a while can you
tell I think I think everybody can tell
but anyway we do have 3 mods up for the
boat as well a list real Bosma inspired
treehouse hmm only because we haven't
done a house mod like our player home
mod in forever so um it was recommended
to us as all of them are every week
yeah a Bosma treehouse
be nice the next one is you army rock
the first Dragonborn fee - basically if
you want to start off your game if you
would going to re-roll as Mirek from the
Dragonborn DLC so maybe that's worth
checking out or maybe you would like to
check out cramped warehouse storage and
crafting which looks kind of cool like
if you're one of those people who likes
to just bung in one place and so based
around like a giant shed yes a giant
shed man shed man shed do let us know
which of those three you would like to
see in next week's show you can do that
by going to the usual link which is
tinyurl.com forward slash ready semi
blog update my blog you've never heard
that before have you
no I have yeah it just tickles me every
time ready semi blog head over there
we'll put the vote link in and you can
cast your vote however you wish maybe
multiple times I think I'm not sure I
think I said it so you can do that if
you want but it's all rigged it is
rigged and then I just pick my favorite
one anyway um Lucy thank you very much
for joining me back on the show thank
you for having it's always good to have
you on here
even with your really really bad puns
which I hope all made it into this
week's episode there have been so very
many and singing uh singing was good oh
yeah oh yes I'm ill this he's always ill
anyway thank you very much for joining
me I'm sorry that it wasn't the cam Lucy
episode as promised I'm sure we'll have
one of those soon enough as soon as cams
back from his holiday in Barcelona
having some fun in the Sun yeah getting
bronzed
yeah those Scots are so well known to do
all right be sure to tune in next week
Lucy how can people get in touch with
you you can find me on Twitter at Lucy
James games lovely and you can get me at
Ready Steady Go we will see you next
week